men are making choices for us women
about birth control abortion health care
everything and we can't even have a say
on it cuz everyone even hear us I have
mine on feminists in the left spotlight
at my feminists in the right spotlight
the feminist movement has changed from
its original definition
[Music]
the reason why I hesitated is because I
started to think about who is most
served by mainstream feminism I don't
personally think that that has changed I
think that white heterosexual
cisgendered women are most served by
mainstream feminism when I heard the
definition of feminist right I was like
a feminist like yeah you know I believe
in equality the sexes of course they do
but it changed the more that I
researched the movement the more that I
saw how mainstream media portrayed it
and to me it's like there's a lot of
issues that happened to men in
disproportionate amounts that are always
overlooked that you know no one talks
about the suicide rate no one talks
about the homelessness rate for men and
it sucks because if your whole movement
is based around equality of the sexes
right and to make sure both sexes are
equaled and that covers the whole the
whole spectrum right it's not just one
sex it's equality the title of feminists
inherently excludes men interesting but
the definition doesn't male privilege is
real
it's not lost on me how many more men
are in academia and in higher education
women are called more often to put their
careers on hold in order to have
children or for whatever other reasons
that's just kind of the way I see it
manifesting most in my life is just
seeing how hard it is to be an
intellectual woman in academia my name
is faith and I am NOT a feminist I am a
strong woman and I was raised by strong
women but I cannot get behind a few of
the core ideals of what it often means
to be a feminist so I do not identify as
one my mother is a teacher she has her
master she has years and years of
experience and yet her place within a
school her place within as far as like
authority over students is not the same
as a man and I think that's an
inequality that I've just been shown
from my mother who comes home and says
you know I just had the worst day of
work because I was uncomfortable the
entire time or I had a strange
experience with a male student who just
like would not listen to a word I said
it wasn't connecting it wasn't until I
brought in the vice principal who was
male or another teacher who was male
that things could be kind of squashed
and covered
just growing up I would say that overall
our our school systems are more geared
towards women there's more female
teachers and that's how our children are
raised you know the thing is that you
were alluding to your mom has to deal
with those difficulties that a man would
not have to deal with and then have to
deal with a lot of difficulties that
most women wouldn't have to deal with we
do benefit from certain privileges but
so do women I think you considered it a
privilege that women there are more
women in the teaching profession but you
should also consider that other options
weren't necessarily or historically
available to women because they were
considered to be more nurturing a lot of
women were pushed into that field still
women are choosing these majors in
choosing their region of study whereas
men are tending to choose higher paying
majors they're choosing more to go into
STEM fields and such like that and
reaping the financial benefits while
women are also reaping their own
happiness benefits of going into a field
that they enjoy if I were born the
opposite sex my life would be easier
I started to walk over just thinking
inherently the privileges that men in
this society have and how they're able
to navigate far easier and and all of
that stuff and then I thought what it
would be like to be a black man in this
society and I don't know that it would
be any easier
I am first-generation mexican-american I
have two Mexican parents if I were to be
born a male Mexican it'd be so much
easier for just that group I try to
break off from those stereotypes of
Melanie gets a table ready for dinner
excuse me I have two brothers that can
do the exact same thing you know why
can't they do it why do I have to do it
my name is Melanie Valdez and I am on
the feminist side I had an incident
where I was sexually assaulted and that
changed my whole perspective
if I was born any other thing than I am
I would have to struggle differently
than I have already struggled and you
know compared to some people in you know
minorities or some people that are white
some people that are way to struggle
more than me there's always a positive
and a negative that you're born with and
it's how you utilize that and get over
it that I think is important rather than
focusing on if I was born this or if I
was born that I think it is kind of what
we make of it and I'd almost say that to
want to be anything different than what
we are is possibly even defeating the
purpose of the feminist movement a big
part of feminism is telling women that
they're worth it already that they're
already enough I have a little sister I
have friends who were told by their by
their father by their older brother that
you are enough and now they're doing
whatever they want because they were
told they could they were given the
opportunity from the beginning and they
weren't told well if you were man you
could no no no they were told you are a
woman and you can because of who you are
not sure that having a community that
affirms who you are is enough if the
society and the structure and the laws
and the policies that govern tell you
otherwise my parents told me I could do
whatever I want to do and so I went to
law school and I'm an attorney and I
write but I don't make as much as my my
coworker who does the exact same thing
and who I'm probably a more qualified
then from the statistics that I read
there was no wage gap bills and earnings
generally it's your understanding that
there is no wage gap between men and
women yes there's nine different
positions different different schooling
can also be a factor you can have the
same degree but from two different
schools and they'll pay someone with
from a better school different how the
interviews go even negotiable
you know entry salaries why then are
women choosing jobs that pay less
culture
men and women need to work together to
create equality
I think one of the reasons that I can
take issue with certain types of
feminism is it does come across as anti
man sometimes it comes across as it's
your fault you know if I go to a women's
March and I see signs that say smash the
patriarchy and like our P word bites
back and stuff like that that's as much
as that speaking against you know an
oppressive top culture that's speaking
to all men and I don't see that as
helpful well I think all men benefit
from patriarchy I mean you need to
acknowledge your privilege first if
people could hear that about themselves
and not be defensive I think that we
could probably push the needle forward a
lot faster something that plagues the
feminist movement is that there's this
idea that in order to gain equal footing
the other side has to be emasculated or
has to be dropped down and it's not this
isn't pie you know what I mean just cuz
I get a slice doesn't mean you get good
you get less right yeah advocating for
women's rights doesn't infringe upon
men's rights right you know first and
second wave feminism were very clear in
the very particular things that they
were trying to accomplish you had first
wave feminism which was very clearly you
know trying to get the right to vote
second wave feminism right after like
World War two and such helping women
progress in the workplace and such and
now I see third wave feminism and it is
a broken apart can be lost movement that
goes in so many directions has so many
extra qualifiers and I think about I was
talking to one of my friends who went to
the women's March with a pro-life
feminist group and she said on multiple
accounts they were asked to leave
because that's not why the women's march
was happening and they were they were
against the movement and so you have all
these different types of feminism there
doesn't seem to be a clear center and a
clear desire and I hear people call
themselves feminists for all different
reasons and with some of them I would
agree and I would call myself a feminist
for those reasons but because it's so
all over the place I just can't colonize
if feminists can make a concise push
towards one issue together what I would
I be willing to join if I agreed with
the point yes if I agreed with what the
movement was going for yes as if it's
just not sure that I'm concerned whether
or not you want to join as it would be
happy it's not not part of the issue but
that's segregating Jen that's that's
segregating genders if you're saying
that you don't care about my opinion as
a man about reshaping and forming my
feminism in a way that is digestible for
you as a man so what's the current one
message the definition of feminism
across the board is the social political
and economic equality of the sexes yes
why are we only talking about the female
inequalities why aren't we talking about
the male in you well you do not have the
same experience we do not you are not
oppressed in the same ways that I am no
and I'm sure you're not oppressed in the
same ways that I am more of our world
leaders should be women
let's talk about Fred like this like
abortion those who signed the bill in
the room with Trump they were all white
men I did not see a single woman it just
doesn't matter if it's a white woman I
did not take a single woman in there so
those men are making choices for us
woman about birth control abortion
health care everything and we we can't
even have a say on it because they won't
even hear us I don't view it as we
should have more women in office I view
it as we should have the most qualified
people in office if you have an issue
with you know the bill being signed by
white men
I believe that voting for Congress
people that are women or you know
whoever you review and believe we're the
most qualified will put those people in
power if we are talking about the last
election I believe that the most
qualified candidate did not win people
need to really consider what role gender
played in that just logically the people
that they're representing are both men
and women so the people representing us
should be men and women and we'd be
really hard for me to ever understand
why people wouldn't think that there
should be more women in leadership
I love women I love being a woman I love
strong women I was raised by strong
women I don't agree with all of the
things that are traditionally included
in feminist beliefs like I have a
different view on abortion then you guys
so that's a big deal for me that's one
of the most important things to me I'm a
Christian and that's just one of my
beliefs so that's kind of for me that's
one of the driving forces why I don't
identify as a feminist to divide into
into two teams gender wise is is not
Spartan it's not often what we do but it
is sometimes and how do we avoid that
and how do we avoid that separation how
do we make it a collective effort even
though I'm a conservative white man and
you know there are different views than
me and I don't want to force you to
agree with me
I don't want to change your mind in that
way but I want to see how I can still
work with you fully and be on your team
and you can be online as we disagree
agreeably thank you everyone for
probably the most respectful middle
ground I've ever seen hey guys this is
jason from jewbilee thank you so much
for watching another episode of middle
ground we hope you enjoyed it as always
please let us know in the comments below
what your thoughts are as well as if
you've got any suggestions for any new
episodes believe it or not we do read
all of your comments so thank you as
always please click here for more videos
click here to subscribe and we'll see
you
[Music]